[Music]
fire and blood will rain again and you
can expect to see the blackfyre
rebellions in the later seasons of house
of the dragon
the upcoming game of thrones prequel
sirius house of the dragon is based on
the george rr martin's targaryen history
book fire and blood
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood vol
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that
iconic seat all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart
in other words it covers events from
aegon's conquest to the dance of the
dragons
that's fire and blood vol 1. house of
the dragon will starve with a
up towards the dance of the dragons in
early seasons we'll cover the dance
itself
later seasons however will be based on
george r martin's yet unfinished fire
and blood vol 2 book
the atana released fire and blood vol 2
will continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon
iii's reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
how do i know the second part of the
targaryen history will cover all of that
because georgia martin himself revealed
it visery's son aegon iv
aegon the unworthy takes over and he's a
very colorful figure himself i
obviously drew on henry the eighth for
him you know
henry the eighth had six wives aegon the
unworthy had nine mistresses and they
were all exist in my head i know who
they all were and what happened to each
of them and who was
who had their head chopped off and who
uh you know had affairs and who did what
so there's a lot of
cool material that and then you get into
the blackfyre rebellions
which were five i've referred to them
frequently
so i'll get all the details on the
blackfire rebellions and
ultimately we'll get up to the the mad
king and roberts rebellion
and wow that's where i'll draw it to a
close
but what am i going to write it well i
got to finish winds of winter first and
firing blood volume 1 it has 700 pages
in comparison the book material game of
thrones show used was 4
000 pages with the additional summary
from georgia martin about the ending
this prequel will last at least as long
as game of thrones
and to achieve that the showrunners will
use fire and blood volume 2 material
and as i already said the main events of
it are the blackfyre rebellions and the
robert's rebellion
so this is something you will see on
screen in the later seasons of house of
the dragon
the first blackfyre rebellion originally
called the blackfyre rebellion was a war
fought between the loyalist forces of
king there on the second targaryen
and the rebel forces of his half-brother
daemon the first blackfyre
daemon the first blackfyre born daemon
waters was a bastard son of king aegon
iv targaryen
and princess dana targaryen legitimized
by his father upon the latter's death
daemon took the name blackfyre for
himself after the ancestral will
reinstill sword of house targaryen
which his father also bequeathed to him
despite his bastard status daemon
believed himself the rightful heir to
the armed round
as his father's firstborn and favorite
child
and ignited a bloody civil war that
divided the seven kingdoms against his
half-brother daeron the second targaryen
but let's get a bit back to see how it
all started
after king baylor the first targaryen
made peace with dorne
he returned to king's landing and
annulled his marriage to his eldest
sister dana
he then locked dana so she could not
tempt the lusts of men
however dana escaped her imprisonment on
several occasions
and towards the end of her brother's
reign became pregnant by her cousin
prince aegon
in late 170ac she gave birth to
ambassador's son
whom she named the daemon waters baylor
the first in response to damon's birth
began a 40-day fast
which eventually caused his death in
171ac
king aegon iv targaryen ascended the
iron throne in 172 ac
in addition to his unacknowledged
bastard son by dana
king aegon iv targaryen head by his
marriage to his sister neres
a trueborn son named daeron born in
month 53 ac
and the daughter daenerys born in 172 ac
aegon often clashed with prince daeron
during his reign
with darren opposing the ideas and the
corrupt style of rule of his father
aegon on the other hand despised his
sister wife narys
and his younger brother prince aemond
and dragonite
to both of whom prince daron was close
around the same time rumors began to
circulate
instigated by king aegon himself the
daeron was a bastard
born of adultery between his siblings
neres and aemon
for the first time although not the last
aegon threatened to name one of his
bastard son as is heir over daeron
the rumors about daeron's parentage
forever remained
but despite aegon's threats and japes
daron was never formally disowned
meanwhile two factions began to form at
court
one supporting the corrupt reign of
aegon iv and the other supporting
derwen in 182 ac aegon knighted his
bastard son damon waters
after the boy won a squire's turning at
the age of 12
aegon publicly bestowed blackfyre one of
the valyrian steel swords of house
targaryen
on daemon as well finally acknowledging
him there were some who felt that the
sword symbolized the monarchy
as it had been the sword of king aegon
the first targaryen to conquer
and had been passed on from king to king
ever since
aegon's public gift of the sword
eventually started the talk that daemon
should be a king
following the acquisition of the sword
the daemon took the name blackfyre for
himself
in early 184 ac king aegon iv targaryen
legitimized all of his bastards on his
deathbed
prince daeron ascended the throne as
king thereon the second targaryen
and did all he could to keep the nobly
born great bastards close
while daeron had chosen to be crowned
with his father's crown
rumors about his legitimacy remained
deron was not a warrior
and while prince baylor daeron's zelda's
son by his dornish wife
was all that could be desired in a
warrior baylor had the looks of a martel
and not like daemon blackfyre of a
targaryen
nobles and knights from the dornish
marches began to mistrust both deron and
baylor
these same people looked at daemon
blackfyre the bastard son of king aegon
iv targaryen
and his cousin princess dana targaryen
and saw in him a warrior
grown tall and powerful with the
hallmarks of old valyria
deep purple eyes silver gold hair down
to his shoulders
who was described as having had an
almost inhumane beauty
being half a god among mortal men
daemon had come to resemble aegon the
conqueror in appearance according to his
supporters
his armor was ornate and costly all
black and red plate
and his war helm was distinctive with
bat-like stale dragon wings on the sides
daemon matured into a man of
considerable charm and strength
mastering all weapons of the battlefield
but with a sword blackfyre
in hand he was said to fight like the
warrior himself
he won friends easily and women were
drawn to him
married to rohan of tyroshin 184 ac
his twin sons aegon and aemon were born
later that same year
six other sons and at least two
daughters followed during the years to
come
daemon's supporters claimed that daemon
had desired his half-sister
princess daenerys and the singer's claim
that she loved him as well
it said that aegon who had seen more
profit in the match with tyrosh
had promised daemon that he could have
more than one bride
daeron however did not agree the dornish
concessions and influence
the sudden change of dornish enemies to
dornish allies
theron's rumored the legitimacy and they
gone the fort's public gift of the sword
of kings to daemon
all were part of the seeds from which
the first blackfyre rebellion grew
still it took many years for the actual
rebellion to begin
there was no final insult that resulted
in declaration of daemon's claim
additionally he had counselors who urged
him to rebel
and many famous warriors who disagreed
with the peace with dorne sought him out
the first blackfyre rebellion finally
broke out in 196 ac
it lasted almost one year and divided
the seven kingdoms
daemon's decision to claim the throne
had been made rashly
and word soon reached their own score
that daemon meant to declare within a
month
it's been suggested by archmaestermirian
that bryden rivers
another one of fagon the fourth's
bastard sons who later went on to become
the three-eyed raven
and who we met hundred years later in
game of thrones
was involved in the news reaching daron
the kingsguard was sent
to arrest daemon but with the aid of
mastery charms of the red keep daemon
managed to escape
imprisonment daemon reversed the colors
of house targaryen
taking for his own schedule a black
dragon on a red field
which led to his nickname the black
dragon with their on becoming known as
the red dragon
and began to mint his own coinage over
the course of the war battles were
fought between the rebels and loyalists
in amongst other places the whale the
westerlands
the riverlands and the reach half the
realm declared for daemon
ser quentin ball attacked the
westerlands killing lord lefford at the
gates of lannisport
and then defeating lord damon lannister
in turn
lord leo tyrell participated in the
first blackfyre rebellion as well
fighting on behalf of house targaryen he
won notable victories in the reach
against daemon blackfyre supporters
a key general fireball was slain on the
eve of the battle of the red grass field
by a common archer
the final conflict of the first
blackfyre rebellion was the battle of
the red grass field
in late 196 ac lord leoterrell's forces
could not gather quickly enough to
arrive in time for the battle
house serene did participate as lord don
orren led the vanguard of the targaryen
forces
however daemon blackfyre shattered his
lines
leaving the loyalists in peril until
sergey and corbrey of the kingsguard
arrived with reinforcements
sergwayne corbray and daemon blackfire
came face to
face during the battle their epic dual
image daemon willed it the valyrian
steel sword blackfyre and gwen the
valyrian steel sword lady forlorn
is said to have lasted nearly an hour
before daemon gained the upper hand
core brave was wounded but daemon
dismounted
preventing corbray from being trampled
and commanded that he was taken on the
field
while daemon was doing this honorable
deed his half-brother brined in rivers
with his archers the raven's teeth
had captured and assumed a position atop
the vaping ridge
which overlooked the battlefield and
allowed them to rain arrows down among
daemon
and his commanders demons heir aegon
died first followed by
daemon himself when daemon's second son
aegon's twin brother aemon took up
blackfyre
he was slain as well with daemon dead
the rebels began to rout
agor rivers claimed blackfyre and
rallied the rebels by leading
a charge against the raven's teeth but
was eventually forced to flee
when prince baylor arrived with a host
of doran's spearmen and stormlanders
while his younger brother prince macor
rallied what remained of the van
as such baylor crushed the rebel army
against maker shield wall
the move later called the hammer and the
animal
ten thousand men died and many more were
maimed and wounded
the first blackfyre rebellion left its
mark upon westeros
for years to come asking a man better he
had fought for the black dragon or the
red was considered a dangerous question
agor rivers was able to recover the
sword blackfyre from the battlefield
and escape to the free cities together
with daemon's widow and remaining
children
eventually ending up in tyrosh in exile
daemon's descendants continued their
struggle for the armed throne
resulting in four more rebellions second
third and fourth blackfyre rebellion
and the war of the nine penny kings
these attempts led to the arrest of
daemon's second son daemon
and the deaths of his third and fifth
son hagon and aines
as well as the death of a grandson also
named aemon daemon's last male
descendant meliss was slain during the
war of the nine penny kings
by sir barst and selmy ending the
blackfyre threat
that's the story of the blackfyre
rebellion thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this video please give it
a big thumbs up and i hope to see you in
the next one
peace